من راس الناقوره على الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه مراسل الجزيره الغاز كرام ومن
قليل قرب الحدود اللدانيه الاسرائيليه
مراسل الجزيره
جونيطانيوس نبدا اولا معك الياس ضمن هناك
جمله من التطورات التي تحدث في هذه
اللحظات لا نعرف نتائج الاجتماع الذي
يراسه نتنياهو مع كبار قاده الامريكيين
ومجلس الوزراء الامنيه المصغر
وكذلك هناك تصريحات لوزير الدفاع الشرفيه
الى انه اصدر تعليماته للجيش بالتحضير
لخيارات الرد على لبنان كما قال اثر
الهجوم الصاروخي ما هو تفسيرك وتفاصيل كل
هذه التطورات في اللحظات الاخيره
بالفعل جمال وهذا البيان صدر عن وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يو اف جلنت الذي قال في
عقابي تقييم امني بانه امر واصدر تعليماته
للجيش الاسرائيلي بالتحضير لكافه الخيارات
للرد على لبنان اثر الهجوم الصاروخي
ونشيرنا الى هذا الخبر العاجل الذي ورد
قبل قليل وهو تاكيد ايضا من جانب الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذي يؤكد سقوط او تعرض بلده
المطله على الحدود مع لبنان في القطاع
الشرقي للحدود لاطلاق قذائف هاون مساء هذا
اليوم وهذا يعني جمال بان كل البلدات
الاسرائيليه من القطاع من اقصى القطاع
الشرقي الى اقصى القطاع الغربي حيث نتواجد
هنا في راس الناقوره قد اصبحت تحت مرمى
الصواريخ التي وجهت باتجاهها من الاراضي
اللبنانيه عصر هذا اليوم
والمؤكد من الجانب الاسرائيلي كما يبدو هو
ان الرد الاسرائيلي اتن وهذا ما تدرسه
الان الاجهزه الامنيه الرد جمال قد يكون
على جبهات متعدده ولي نصرا في لبنان على
اعتبار ان الجيش الاسرائيلي من ناحيه وجه
اصابع الاتهام الى حركه حماس بالوقوف وراء
الهجوم من الاراضي اللبنانيه باتجاه
البلدات الاسرائيليه وهذا يعني بان قطاع
غزه ربما يكون احد الاهداف للرد بالنسبه
لاسرائيل على هذا الهجوم ايضا جنوب لبنان
مواقع ومقر تابعه للفصائل الفلسطينيه سواء
كان ذلك لحماس او الجهاد الاسلامي او
الجبهه الشعبيه وغيرها من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه ربما تكون ايضا عرضه لهذه
الضربات ولا يستبعد كذلك بان تطال الهجمات
من سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي ايضا الاراضي
السوريه وتوجيه ضربات ربما لمقار ولمواقع
تابعه للمليشيات الايرانيه على اعتبار ان
اسرائيل تقول وتلمح بان ايران ربما تكون
هي التي شجعت حركه حماس للقيام بهذا
الهجوم الواسع وغير المسبوق على الاراضي
الاسرائيليه منذ عام
2006 اذا كل هذه الامور تؤخذ بعين اختبار
لكننا يؤخذ اكثر بعين الاعتبار الان في كل
ما تتدرسه الاجهزه الامنيه والمؤسسه
الامنيه في اسرائيل هو ربما ان اسرائيل
تريد ان ترد لكنها تريد بنفس الوقت ان
تمنع حزب الله او ان تبقي حزب الله خارج
معادله الرد والرد الفعل على اي هجوم قد
تقوم به على الاراضي اللبنانيه اسرائيل لا
تستبعد او على الاقل هذا ما يفهم من
تصريحات الناطق بلسان الجيش الاسرائيلي
الذي يقول بان اسرائيل تحمل المسؤوليه
للدوله اللبنانيه
بانها لم تمنع هذا الهجوم من اراضيها وهذا
ربما يؤشر على ان اسرائيل قد تتدارس ايضا
احتمال الرد على مواقع استراتيجيه او
مواقع تابعه للدوله اللبنانيه كمقر ربما
تكون حكوميه او مؤسستيه او استراتيجيه او
حتى موانئ ومطارات كما فعلت في حروب سابقه
على على ربما
قبل قليل هناك محاوله لتحقيق حزب الله
هيئه البث الايطاليه تقول مجلس الوزراء
سيتخذ قرارا بشان الرد على اطلاق الصواريخ
من لبنان دون جري حزب الله للحرب كيف
بالفعل وداني وداني فقط اشير هنا الى ان
اسرائيل لديها حساب طويل مع مع حزب الله
وهي تريد ان تستغل ربما اي ازمه قد تكون
من الاراضي اللبنانيه لتنفيذ هجمات على
بعض المقاهر جمال القريبه من الحدود
المتاخمه للحدود حزب الله عاد خلافا من
وجهه نظره اسرائيل خلافا لقرار الامم
المتحده 1701 الذي انهى الحرب على لبنان
في عام 2006 عاده واقام مقرات تابعه له
على مقربه من الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه هل ستكون هذه المقار وهذا سؤال
مهم وهي قريبه جدا وليس في العمق
الاستراتيجي لحزب الله لكنها قريبه جدا
وهي مواقع رصد ومراقبه للحدود الاسرائيليه
هل سيلجا الجيش الاسرائيلي الى ضرب بعضها
او ضربها كلها على طول الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه على اعتبار ان المواجهه تبقى
منحصره في اطار الحدود وهو ايضا الجيش
الاسرائيلي يتحين فرصه ايضا لتوجيه ضربات
لمواقع استراتيجيه تابعه لحزب الله تح
ديدا تلك التي يتم فيها تطوير الصواريخ
بعيده المدى وجعلها اكثر دقه لضرب العمق
الاسرائيلي